Let's look at the solution to our tree height reduction quiz. We had this code,
and we are trying to transform it through tree height reduction into something
that minimizes the overall number of cycles it takes to execute this code.
Here, the code takes six cycles to do because each of the instructions depends
on the previous one. Now, when doing tree height reduction, what we need to do
is really figure out what is the expression that this is trying to compute. And
then, rewrite that expression. So, here's what we have here. We have R1 plus R2.
Put the result in R10. Then subtract R3. Then add R4.
Then subtract R5. Then add R6. Then subtract R7.
So this is what we are trying to compute. How do we compute it with tree height
reduction? Well, the idea is to compute R1 and R2. That's what we're doing here.
And then, compute the rest of the things and then add them up in R3.
So here, what we need to do is we need to add up four numbers and then
subtract three numbers from that. So first, we will add up the four numbers.
We already added up R1 and R2. Now we're going to add up R4 and R6. Next,
the result of our two additions are going to be combined. So
we're going to add up what we have for R1 and R2 and what we have for R4 and R6.
So now in R10 we have the R1 plus R2 plus R4 plus R6.
Now we're going to subtract R3, R5 and
R7 from it. If we do it one at a time, that's going to be slow. So
what we are going to do is we are going to add up R3, R5 and R7 and
then subtract that from our R10. That's why we ave two adds here.
So clearly, what we are doing here is we are simply adding up R3, R5. And
then R7 is added to that. So this needs to be R11.
So now R11 has R3 plus R5 plus R7. And
now we subtract that from R10, and we get the final answer in R10.
Now let us see how many cycles we need to do this. To do that,
let's draw the dependencies. Here we have the dependence again. Like this.
So each instruction needed to be done right after the previous one is done.
Here there is no dependence between these two. There is a dependence here and
here. So the third instruction is to wait for the first two to complete.
There is now, no dependence here. So this one can be done right away,
even though it's the fourth instruction in our code. And
then there is a dependence here. And then finally, there is a dependence here,
and also our final R10 here needs to be brought this way.
So, if you look at what can be done in the first cycle, this can be done in
the first cycle, and so can this. This cannot because it has to wait. This can.
So this is also done in the first cycle. And then, this has to wait for that and
so on. So in our first cycle, we've already done three instructions,
half of the instructions that we had. In the second cycle, we can do this,
because these two complete in the first cycle. We can do this. Because it
only waits for this and that's been done. And, finally, in the third cycle we
have to do this because it has to wait for the results of the second cycle. So
we have completed our six instructions now in three cycles and we've got
an ILP of 2, which is twice as good as we had before the tree height reduction.